[Musique]
cette exposition elle a été conçue et
pensée et réalisée dans le cadre de la
saison culturelle à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines objectif image
la question que nous nous sommes posée
c'est qu'est-ce que voir qu'est-ce que
regarder dans ce monde où nous sommes
entourés d'image on a une partie
perception qui est dans la chapelle et
une partie illusion qui est dans le
bâtiment garde nous sommes actuellement
[Musique]
qui a tout ce qui concerne la partie
illusion d'optique donc de la chose la
plus simple à la chose la plus
compliquée et ensuite vous avez toute
une partie sur la réalité virtuelle
la réalité augmentée pour la partie
artistique
on est sur la notion de rendre visible
l'invisible
on a une oeuvre qui a été coproduite par
donc la commanderie et l'artiste 9
d'eric woerth qui s'appelle rvb 255 et
cette oeuvre la montre en fait donc
capte notre image et prend le prétexte
d'un petit notre image et du coup rend
visible à la fois la lumière sur nous et
en même temps c'est le prétexte pour
montrer la bataille des couleurs entre
le hervé les dons ont joué dans la
partie scientifique on va partir de
qu'est ce que c'est l'oeil
qu'est ce que c'est voir et puis sur la
partie installations artistiques
nous avons décidé de prendre un parti
pris un point de vue donc d'explorer
l'oeil écoute à la fois vous avez des
petits cartel qui vous explique les
choses et à la fois il ya un côté
manipulation est donc un côté ludique et
autant les enfants que les adultes
ça fonctionne très bien on se laisse
prendre faut se laisser d'ailleurs il
faut se laisser prendre
c'est l'idée
[Musique]
moi